all right a bit of a fact check this
morning after Fox News host Tucker
Carlson aired previously unseen video of
The Assault on the capitol on his show
last night what Carlson did is use
selected clips from surveillance tapes
provided to him by house Speaker Kevin
McCarthy to claim falsely that
journalists and lawmakers lied about the
January 6th attack on the capitol Scott
McFarland is in Washington Scott good
morning to you you've been following
this very closely what stood out to you
yeah Tony good morning The Narrative
last night ignores the tens of thousands
of pages of court filings we've read and
the tonnage of footage already released
by the justice department and shown in
open court and it ignores the powerful
and at times tearful accounts of injured
officers who are testifying under oath
Carlson called January 6th quote mostly
peaceful and meek with a small percent
that was violent he showed limited
edited footage Monday night on his
program that draws an audience of 3.5
million viewers and pointed to images of
a few protesters shuffling through the
halls of Congress but our CBS News
Review found more than 300 people
charged with actually assaulting police
amid the mob and body worn camera like
this shows attackers using spray sticks
and baseball bats stolen riot shields
sometimes they're bare hands to beat
police officers and damage the capital
and the days after the attack five
officers who served at the Capitol that
day died that includes Capital officer
Brian sicknick Carlson showed video of
sicknick who died one day after the
attack walking through the capitol
Carlson saying sicknic quote looked
healthy and vigorous but according to
the report from the D.C chief medical
examiner officer sicknick died after
suffering Two Strokes at the base of his
brain stem caused by a blood clot he
collapsed hours after being assaulted by
the rioters his family released a
statement to CBS News Monday night
saying in part on video officer sick
Nick looks like he managed to take off
the chemical irritants and resume his
duties his sense of Duty sent him back
in and no doubt contributed to his
succumbing to his injuries the chair of
the house January 6 committee blasted
speaker Kevin McCarthy for giving the
footage to Carlson to quote spew lies
and propaganda the speaker defended his
decision saying those tapes belonged to
the American public Tony
uh Scott you've covered this for two
years have been all these court cases
that you mentioned uh have have legal
teams defendants been given access to
video like this what have you learned
from the the judicial process I guess is
the question yeah Tony this isn't just
the largest criminal investigation in
American history it's potentially one of
the most photographed there are
thousands of hours of footage some
defense attorneys have said it's almost
too much some of the assaults shown are
just medieval but the violence that day
came in waves Tucker Carlson showed some
of the walking around and Milling about
but the fighting wasn't constant it
wasn't everywhere it just happened at
times Carlson also focused on the case
of Jacob chansley the so-called Q Anon
Shaman asking why some of the quieter
moments involving chansley didn't serve
as a trial well chancelly pleaded guilty
and didn't go to trial and he admitted
breaking a police line and riling the
crowd Gail about 500 people have pleaded
guilty in their roles that day and the
FBI is looking to arrest 206 60 more
it is astounding thank you Scott listen
it's okay if you want to show another
side of the thing but at least put it
all in context yeah please don't ignore
that there was an Insurrection that day
that has been shown repeatedly over and
over and over again it's not extremely
upsetting it's like not everyone at
Woodstock took drugs and and slid in the
mud but a lot of people did exactly
Woodstock yeah and think about how those
police officers families still feel
today